the 30-60-90 triangle is one of the
special triangles you will surely come
across in your exams as the name
suggests one angle measures 30 degrees
160 and the remaining one obviously 90
degrees so what's special about it in 30
60 90 triangles if we are given the
length of one side we can easily find
the length of the other two sides so
knowing one sides length gives us the
length of all the sides before you plan
to memorize the relation between the
sides I urge you not to all you need is
to understand something very simple the
side opposite the smaller angle in a
triangle is always smaller so BC which
is the side opposite the 30 degrees will
be smaller than a B which is the side
opposite 60 degrees and this will be
smaller than AC which is the side
opposite the 90 degrees angle this is
the most basic thing we need to
understand the next concept is quite
remarkable these three sides will always
be in the ratio one is 2 root 3 is 2 2
in terms of variables if we say that BC
is a then a B will be a root 3 and AC
will be 2a let's take a couple of
examples let's say we are given that BC
is equal to 2 units then based on this
ratio a B will be 2 root 3 then AC will
be twice this value which is 4 units ok
here's another one
what if we are given the length of a B
as 5 root 3 units BC will be 5 units and
AC will be twice of 5 which is 10 units
what if a B is equal to 2 units this is
interesting if a B is 2 then BC has to
be 2 by root 3 units look at it this way
this times root 3 should give you a B so
2 by root 3 times root 3
is to AC will be just twice of BC which
equals 4 by root 3 but what if we forget
this ratio can be quickly derive it for
that you just need to understand the
equilateral triangle well let's draw one
quickly and name it ABC all we need is
to draw a perpendicular from a on to BC
and call it ad as all angles of an
equilateral triangle are equal this one
will measure 60 degrees these two will
also measure 60 degrees for now just
look at triangle ADC as the sum of
angles of this triangle will also be 180
degrees we get this equation this angle
plus 60 degrees plus 90 is 180 degrees
solving this we get the measure of angle
DAC as 30 degrees so ADC is actually a
30-60-90 triangle if the site of the
equilateral triangle is s units then we
note that DC will be s by 2 units in an
equilateral triangle the perpendicular
from a vertex to the opposite side
divides it into two equal parts now in
this triangle if we are able to find ad
in terms of s we can easily derive a
ratio using the Pythagoras theorem in
triangle ADC
we get this equation solving for ad we
get its value as root 3 by 2 times s now
in this 30-60-90 triangle we have all
sides in terms of s we are interested in
DC is to ad is to AC side opposite 30
side opposite 60 and side opposite 90 DC
is s by 2 ad is root 3 s by 2 and AC is
s multiplying throughout by 2 we get s
is 2 s root 3 is 2 2 s there you go
that's our
one is 2 root 3 is 2 2 so if we forget
the ratio all we need is to draw an
equilateral triangle drop a
perpendicular and solve for the sides of
this triangle